i love reading about stuff that you
couldn't get on
uh saturday night live and one of the
best bits that i heard about
was this idea you came up with
which was half a viagra
and i love this idea for this bit and
what the bit i don't mean to mutilate
your bit but
you pitched the saturday night live you
said let's do a bit half a viagra it's
for guys who don't want to [ __ ] you just
want your dick to look bigger when you
go to the doctor or you're pissing on a
stadium and to me they could
why why can't they put that on saturday
night live there's no way to i don't
know we there's so many bits like that
though we would just try at the table
and even if it works at the table
they're just like we can't produce this
man come on
the other thing i heard about you is you
did write a sketch for saturday night
live that never made it on called wet
coma
yeah i did it was a great idea why did
that not get on wet coma
i think your whole audience is probably
i think i got an idea why what coma
didn't it was like it was uh
owen wilson uh he was he slipped into a
wet coma so he was just moaning in a
hospital bed he so the coma is like a
wet dream so when people came to visit
him he was in the middle of coming and
having a wet dream in his coma
he can't do that on saturday night live
yeah and they're trying to like
yeah we had a wait i remember and it was
stuff like that like that killed at the
table but for whatever reason
we put it in front of the audience
people were baffled like i had this one
i remember larry david hosted i don't
know if we talked about larry david
holtz it was one of my favorite sketches
um he played a guy that that came up
with the california raisins and he
invited keenan
he invited keenan and leslie over to
pitch the california raisins to him he
was like yeah they're raising they sting
motown songs like this is kind of racist
how is it racist
and uh and we had like all these
drawings of like the california raisins
as pimps and
playing basketball and [ __ ]
and the audience saw it and they were
just like absolutely not